[Music]
i love movies from this genre a lot but
i also loved
the retro aspect to it so much the look
of it and and the production design of
it
um
so this is is based on a short story
by stephen king's son that's right
and so i'm wondering how did you come
into contact with the story and then
want to do an adaptation i read uh the
short story when it was first published
16 17 years ago or so uh i just wandered
into the skylight book score bookstore
on endless felis and uh went to their
new horror section and they had five or
six books and 20th century ghosts by joe
hill was one of them and uh
he published at that time uh under that
name and still publishes under that name
but had no idea he was stephen king's
son nobody did he was very uh insistent
on making his own name before anyone
knew who he was or who he was related to
so i read uh the first short story
called best new horror i remember
opening the book and thinking boy this
guy is brave calling his first piece of
fiction horror fiction best new horror
better be good and uh and it was great
and i so i bought the book and i read it
all and the black phone was one of the
short stories in it and i thought about
it since then as a as a great idea just
a great concept for a film
yeah i have to say um you know i'm
generation x i was born in the 70s grew
up in the 80s
in in the heyday of of killers of these
type so
when i watch it i feel like i get
a little extra scared because i remember
being scared because this was really
happening in the time period in which i
grew up
and
you know the the creeper van um
what was it
about
um
you know there's this this this film is
a serial killer movie but it's but it's
with a twist
because it's really more focused on the
victims is is that part of what
attracted you well it was
when i read the short story it was it
was two things it's very deceptive
actually to even
really not realize what a what an
amazing
original idea was to combine a serial
killer story with a ghost story i just
never seen that done in any kind of
effective way before but joe's story was
also told
really empathetically you know i
remember feeling moved by it and feeling
moved by
bruce yamada there was only one victim
in the original story wasn't set in the
70s but just empathy for him empathy for
for uh the finney character and and uh
you know i took me it took me so long to
come around to turn it into a screenplay
because i didn't really know how it was
kind of like the second act of a movie
uh at best and so
the idea of expanding it really and just
gets to the 70s comment the idea came to
me when
i stepped up when i was stepping off the
process of stepping off of
directing the doctor strange sequel and
i had i had been in therapy for three
years mostly dealing with the violence
from my childhood you know and i just
lived in a violent neighborhood like
this kind of a working-class
neighborhood and a lot of violence in my
household and that whole
era and just that that whole
feeling especially in north denver ted
bundy had just come through colorado
killing a bunch of women and escaped the
you know the manson murders had happened
we were all talking about that in
elementary school in middle school and
uh and and i mean my next-door neighbor
my friend from school
knocked on my door when i was nine and
and i answered it it was at night and he
was crying and he said somebody murdered
my mom
and his mother had been abducted and
raped and wrapped in phone wire phone
cord and thrown in the local lake so
it's like
the neighborhood that i lived in was
just that fear and halloween had just
come out uh in you know i think 1977. so
it's just like the idea of the of the
the hidden killer who can snatch you and
take your life was very real thing for
kids at that time
it wasn't and it's wild because it feels
like in the 70s these these killers were
present but they were not being caught
and then in the 1980s
when gacy happened
then they actually started being caught
because i think in the 70s a lot of
people were not reporting that they were
assaulted by these killers so it's very
hard to catch them because people
especially in the midwest were really
ashamed of having been attacked by some
by pedophiles
and um it seems like it all came to a
head so that really made sense to me in
this film that that they're all very
confused about how to get this game yeah
because they didn't understand you know
uh ted bundy was was um
was very instrumental in helping uh the
fbi understand
criminal profiling was basically
invented by the head of the fbi at the
time who who was the only person ted
bundy would speak to and ultimately
confessed all of his crimes to but he
helped him catch the green river killer
which is what uh uh the novel silence of
the lambs was really based on so it all
started to kind of open up at that time
but but yeah they they the concept of
the of of the serial killer was just
beginning to be understood at that time
in the in the late 70s
so let's talk about your incredible cast
um you got ethan hawk
did you was he someone that you thought
of when you were getting ready to cast
this
well apparently yeah i mean was he top
of the list or was he he well he's the
only person i offered the role to but
but i didn't write it with him in mind
you know it was written the the the joe
short story with the the the the killer
he's not called the grabber very much
based on john wayne gacy he was a clown
in the short story he was fat you know
and so
you know it was very obviously an homage
to
to gacy and uh and we adapted the script
that way
and
joe hill was the first person to read
the script because i you know anytime
that i work on adaptations of material
i'm very respectful and want the
approval of whoever
wrote the source material and uh and joe
said and it had just come out and he's
like can't be a clown you got to get rid
of that you know and it was his idea to
make him a magician which i thought was
a great idea um
and uh and the the
in the script that we wrote again he
didn't have masks in the short story but
i liked the idea of him having having a
mask and and in the script i think he
just had like an antique leather devil
mask look at the devil painted on it one
with a smile one with a frown like a
comedy tragedy mask that was it
and uh and i knew that
a lot of if not all of the script was
gonna the character was gonna be behind
a mask
and i just my first thought was i needed
somebody with a really distinctive voice
was really how i jumped quickly to ethan
because i've always thought that his
voice was was
is remarkable nobody sounds like him and
the kind of range and multi multiple
personalities that just exist even when
you're talking to him conversationally
i feel like when i'm talking to him
sometimes he has five different
voices you know ranging from high to
really low and gravelly and he just does
a lot with it and so that was i just
thought boy he would be he would bring a
lot to this and i uh i i called him told
him i had this script he told me i don't
really play villains
it's true that's true and i it didn't
occur to me and i remember him saying it
i mean look i'll read it i'll read it
right away but you know it will have to
be some really you know jack nicholson
and the shining shit that's what he told
me on the phone
and uh and i sent it to him and i
thought he's never gonna do this and
then i woke up in the morning and there
was a voicemail on my phone from ethan
and i played it and it was the voice of
the grabber that you hear in the movie
saying one of the lines from the script
and that was it this is a creepy message
you know in the morning
and that was his way of telling me that
he was going to do it do you want to see
a trick yeah exactly
but but also you know once i had him the
masks
had a lot to do with casting with him
agreeing to do it because i didn't think
i'd get a movie star
to play that role i just you know i just
didn't see that really happening and i
was elated that he wanted to do it and
then when i went into pre-production i
was like i have ethan hawk i kind of
want to see him a little bit you know
and and that started me down the line of
thinking
of the mass being divided that he could
wear sections of it and then it was like
then it sort of expanded into three
masks each of them could be divided in
half and that became really um
important to the character in terms of
what mass is he where when what's he
trying to communicate to terrorize or or
uh
present himself to his to his victims
that mask and the mass design is
terrifying and the whole like it's got
different expressions he's got two
different halves the top half and the
bottom and you can change
he can put on his naughty boy mask or he
can put on his
yeah every day where we i think i spent
more time on that mask than anything in
pre-production because it also occurred
to me while i was prepping it that this
there's no version of this movie
where they don't use that as the main
marketing
feature you know
it also feels like every horror film has
an iconic image from it you know you
know what that is i mean master is big
halloween big tradition yeah halloween
and friday the 13th and ghostface and
and uh and and i i got excited at the
idea of trying to create an iconic mask
but
something that was progressive and new
and did more than what
and also just i like the idea of a you
know the masked
masked serial killer
they're always silent and this one's
really chatty you know and i thought
that was interesting too so and
the idea of the mass being something
that allows him to to converse and allow
he you know he only he always has either
the white
face paint on
uh like at the beginning in his magician
garb or he or you wears the mask and
somehow
ethan really when he saw all the masks
i mean he had a really visceral reaction
to them and said to me very shortly
after that he said i think this is going
to really free me up to do a lot more
with the character because i can let the
mask do what the mask does you know and
i think that
i don't really understand what his
process was in coming up with the the
complexity of that character and the way
he speaks i feel like there's like five
different versions of him the more that
i watched the movie you know um
and uh but i think a lot of that had to
do with the room that he felt like he
had because he could let the mask do
certain so much work on its own did he
did he end up relishing playing a bad
guy in the end oh he had a great time
doing this movie
he did yeah
um so what about the kids are so
phenomenal your lead
i mean when i saw him i was like this
feels like when i saw jodie foster and
taxi driver
he feels like such a discovery he is a
discovery i mean you know both him and
madeleine mcgraw are are i i feel like i
got so lucky to have found both of them
madeleine i found first her agent sent
into the tape
and as soon as i saw it she did she did
the scene uh with the detectives in her
audition tape and i laughed so hard at
the end of it
at the you know you dumb fucking fart
knockers line and but her whole manner i
was just like this just feels like this
character and then when i did call back
auditions with her it was like she is
gwen she really understood that
character
instinctively and i think her
performance
especially in the whipping scene is
spectacular
finney was a much harder find you know i
i got nervous i thought we were we were
running out of time i had seen hundreds
of kids and i just felt like the the
weight of the movie is on his shoulder
and on his shoulders and when i
saw his audition tape
he had never been in a feature film i
think he may have had a manager but i
think that he may if i remember right he
was like in a public school audition
because they were pulling kids out of
drama departments and schools and stuff
like that or just around the company
country he was living in texas at the
time and uh and i uh i did several call
back auditions with him
and i just started to realize wow this
the reservoir of raw talent here
is incredible you know because his
ability to
emotionally process
every take that we would do every scene
without overacting it's in his eyes it's
in his it's in his face in his every
movement just feels so truthful and you
can't teach that you can't direct that
either like i can talk to him about this
is what he's thinking in the scene but
then it's up to the actor to to do that
and to play that and i just feel like he
doesn't miss a beat and that's a talent
that most professional adult actors
don't have frankly yeah
i
looked him up immediately and i was like
i can't wait to see what this guy does
yeah he's i think he's going to have a
big career uh i think he's on for all
mankind the apple series now i i don't
know what he's doing i mean i helped him
get an age i helped him get him repped
at wme so i look out for right
any of the kids that i work out for i
always feel like you know the uncle who
has to sort of make sure that they're
all doing fine you know um but he's i
think he's going to have a big career
um
and then and then all the boys that that
played the victims they were all so
great they were all so individual and
specific
um
was finding them a very difficult thing
to do well the the robin ariano
character was obviously really important
to the movie that's another one i took a
lot it took a long time to find he had
never done
any on-camera work before ever
miguel and he was a he lives in arizona
and
found him through a drama program in a
school and uh and he's
you know he's got star quality too he's
so good in in in playing that character
the other ones believe it or not are
locals in north carolina where we shot
they're just so great and what's
impressive to me
is that those conversations on the phone
with um the bruce yamada character
griffin who's the one who's upside down
you know bent upside down he's his voice
you only see him that one glimpse but
the conversation is amazing that he has
with him um and uh and the paper boy all
three locals from north carolina and
those conversations they that they have
are all single takes either in camera
single takes or in the case of of
griffin it's all you know one audio one
take and the time so the timing is not
editorial the timing is just those kids
just could feel
how to do those scenes the kids
performances felt so fresh like it made
me think of bad news bears like the
original bad news bears high praise um
yeah thank you
just so
like real kids yeah and they are you
know and also just have you worked with
kids before on anything a lot of kids
made sinister you know the kids love
making horror films by the way it's like
halloween every day you know yeah they
love it you know halloween's a kid's
holiday and they love you know
especially the kids who got to put
slashes on their face and blood on their
shirts and stuff like that they really
you know they all cried when they left
um but they they have such a good time
doing this it was the same one sinister
lulu wilson who's has a huge career now
and was in
um mike flanagan show the haunting hill
house
i discovered her when she was six you
know and put her through a lot in uh in
her first horror film and and they just
have a blast they love it they love
doing it yeah
um can you talk a little bit about the
the work what you did with your dp um
finding the look for the film that the
the the quality of the way that it shot
and the lighting
yeah brett is uh uh i can't i i can't
even pronounce his last name i i mess it
up every time i try to say it but brett
uh shot
ready or not and that was i i noticed
the lighting
and the camera work when i saw that film
so i i looked him up and i was really
really admired the work that he did on
that and then he just shot scream and
shot uh episode four of stranger things
which is incredible that fourth episode
of the new season is amazing so he's
done you know he really likes the genre
and he was a he was a great partner in
this because
i told him that you know i'd like to be
really prepared and and so we
um and he does too so we shot listed or
storyboarded every single shot in the
movie um before we started principal
photography so it was a very i just knew
that that basement
you know so much time in that basement
could become very
quickly become very redundant and so
finding a
a visual idea visual design for how to
shoot that space
how to increase the camera movement but
to always justify the camera movement
there's a lot of precision work and the
only way that we could do that in the
33-day schedule that we had which is
short was to be super prepared
but also
what allowed us to do it was that when
in the scenes with the grabber with
ethan
i i i
really wanted to
have faith in the writing and the acting
so there's no real fancy camera work in
any of those scenes it's just kind of
told from their points of view mainly
finney's point of view and uh and i
think that was a good directorial choice
to not get in the way of what they're
just what's
what they're saying what their what's in
their face what's on you know finney's
face in particular and what he's feeling
in those scenes
i just feel like this was such an
immersive experience like you get into
it
you're i i assume we're brought in
because the music because of the
production design because of the look of
it
for you how how is it to create
how do you think of creating like i want
to create a movie where people feels
like they're in the 70s this is the time
period and we're in it it's not going to
be like fake crappy wigs that take
people out of it
that's a good question i mean i had a
really good partner in patty podesta my
production designer i'd worked with her
on the um pilot for snow piercer that i
did and and uh and i just i had a really
really good way of communicating with
her and and what i really wanted to do
was not fetishize the 70s i definitely
didn't want to be nostalgic about any
part of that era and you know that seems
to be the thing you do when you've got
middle school kids you know in the 80s
or the 70s
everybody wants to be nostalgic about
that time and it's just like i don't
feel that way about that time in my life
is you know the primary emotion i
associate with
my life at that age is fear in my whole
childhood just was a lot of fear and so
the 70s look and feel it was more about
trying
it was less about trying to create
something that looked like the 70s and
and get something that felt like the 70s
and i think that it that um that when we
went to north carolina we got really
lucky because i was scouting and i
thought i was going to have to say we
can't shoot here because i just couldn't
find i liked the they had the red brick
houses which look like houses where i
lived
that was great but it wasn't until we
found this one little pocket
area in wilmington
north carolina that had all the chain
link fences and when i found all those
fences i was like oh this this feels
like home you know and it's just not
just the fences but they're rusty and
they're broken and they've got the
barbed x's at the top of them you know
that are just totally unsafe and you
you're cutting your hands on them all
the time and um and that there was just
it was sort of like picking these little
pat
little patches of
visual
material that was there and and i felt
like if we had that and the wardrobes
were right and
and and and this in the sky was overcast
which was really great for for like
denver in that in in the fall
um
it just it just all kind of came
together but again it was all about the
feel of it and not i didn't want anybody
to be watching and going oh i remember
those socks you know or you know
anything like that it was much more
about feeling like uh i actually really
love that i saw i think the pair of
converse that he's wearing with like red
and blue on the side i had a friend that
had those and i'm thrilled when i see
those details i was like oh my god i
love those shoes
uh you know i noticed your your dp also
shoots for um stranger things and that's
another show it's completely immersive
you know in the 1980s yeah and you just
love the details because you're like i
had that freaking jacket i had you know
so for those of us that lived in that
time period
it's it's such a thrill
um
well this is such a fantastic movie
you're off to the new bev after this to
show it they're showing a 35 millimeter
are they gonna show it in 35 again over
there yeah they they made a uh blumhouse
struck a print of it in 35 millimeter
and yeah right and i really like those
guys at the new beverly so i just i
contacted him and said and i saw that i
color timed the print and when i saw it
it's actually
the best looking version of the movie
the 35 millimeter transfer and you know
the stuff on super 8 is shot on super 8
so brett did a great job of
testing stocks and finding the right
super 8 stock for each of those stream
sequences um but the transfer on 35 is
glorious it looks so good so do you does
everybody get a 35
master or
and i told him i said well if it doesn't
matter if you're only making one it's
important to me um he's such a good dude
and uh uh so i went and color timed it
and then uh just like two weeks ago
a delivery guy showed up and jason
struck a 35 millimeter print and sent it
to my house and gave me my own print of
it which is great i really like owning
my own 35 print of it that's fantastic
it's really worth it i mean if you get
to see something in 35 and digital you
really know when you see that projected
you really know the
the experience of santa 35 is really
special yeah it is it's great um
well uh
i think that's all i wanna i have a
tendency to forget my last questions
that that i
feel like there was something else that
i wanted my favorite color is blue
your favorite color is blue no it's
actually green i don't know why i said
that i love blue it's actually
everything i say up here is a lie
you know the last two screenings that
we've had i asked the question they were
marcel the shell and um
[Music]
the other one that we showed brian and
charles i asked them if the you know
pretty young filmmakers if if the mcu
called
are you gonna do it well you're someone
who has the mcu has called you yes they
have
what what's the difference between
making a film like this and making a
film for marvel
uh you know
on the one hand
every film that i've made on the one
hand is exactly the same sinister was a
three million dollar budget this was 17
[Music]
doctor strange was over 200
every movie i've ever made you don't
have enough time and you don't have
enough money you know it's just the same
problem every time um it's it's
i don't know why that is but it always
seems to be that way um i think that um
you know i had a really good experience
at marvel i really did i i
think that kevin feige you know
people a lot of people have different
attitudes about him my experience with
him on making that movie
was you know uh
he was a great creative partner i think
he's the only producer
and certainly the only studio head that
i think deserves to be called an artist
he really
tortures himself over the creative
process that he's in to make sure you
know wanting the movies to be really
good um that was the case at least when
i was making doctor strange and um and
but it is a very collaborative process
you know there is a there's a lot of um
of uh
you know
servicing
what makes a marvel movie a marvel movie
i got a lot less of that i think than
most directors though because doctor
strange didn't have any mcu tie-ins at
all you know how fortunate to be able to
make one of those movies and make it
from scratch originally and i think that
they were before i came along i came in
with a huge presentation a 90-minute
presentation of what i thought i loved
the comics so much and i don't think
they really knew what they wanted to do
with those comics and they they kevin
really trusted my vision for it you know
and let me make a very weird very
psychedelic movie um and was was really
supportive all the way along so i don't
have anything bad to say about that
but there is a big difference between
that and making something personal and
there's a lot of personal things in
doctor strange it's a spiritual movie
it's a psychedelic movie those were all
things that i really wanted to do
but um but you know something like this
i mean i
wrote the script with my writing partner
cargill and in six weeks it's deeply
personal movie all the kids in this were
taken directly from kids that i knew as
a kid
you know and uh and i never got
forced to change anything i you know
there was nothing in the script and
there was nothing in the making of the
movie that isn't the way that i wanted
to to be
and uh and that's to jason blum's credit
you know he just really trusted me to to
to do things the way that i wanted to do
them yeah and and we did i didn't have
to reshoot anything it was great you
know so that's that's the that's the
benefit of having
uh some credibility as a filmmaker and
then having a producer like jason who
essentially gives you a final cut
thank you for talking about that i you
know i um
watch every film that i can get my hands
on including marvel and films like yours
i think anybody that's against marvel
is really just against that becoming the
only thing that we make that's the only
thing that we're interested in making in
our industry yeah i have a very
different attitude about that than a lot
of people do you know i mean i
grew up you know the one real saving
grace in my household is that my family
did love movies my parents liked movies
so i saw a ton of movies growing up you
know we would go to the matinee
and then grab fast food and then go to a
double feature at the drive-in so i'd
see like three movies in one day you
know which in at that time people just
didn't do
and uh and i saw so many movies growing
up and all genres of movies didn't see
any international cinema i discovered
that you know after high school but i
think that um
i i just feel like
the love for movies
is something you either have or you
don't kevin and those people victoria
lou and marvel they love movies you know
and they don't just love their movies
they love in fact that was my running
joke with kevin whenever he would give
me a note that i didn't like on doctor
strange i would always say to him why do
you hate movies so much
you know that was my running joke and
then one day one day i said it to him
and he stopped and goes i don't hate
movies i just hate our movies which i
which is because again he's so so
brooding about every every show but here
just as a long answer but it's important
you know i think that i remember that
time of growing up and going to the
multiplexes and seeing whatever i could
and then you know going to college and
then going to film school and exploring
international cinema which is probably
personally my favorite you know japanese
cinnamon european historical european
cinema is probably my favorite
those are my favorite movies in the
world
but there's more options of great things
to watch now
than ever
you know and i learned the history of
international cinema on vhs you know i
don't discount those experiences so i
think the fact that we can see things in
in on hd tvs and in good transfers
and that there's so much new content
streaming and there's always a lot of
movies out in theaters i've nev i i
watch a lot of movies and i've never run
out of great shit to go watch
so the idea that you know marvel is from
ruining movies and you know they've
taken over the multiplexes and it's like
hey man if you're if you're running out
of great interesting
independent films to see
you you see more movies than i ever have
and i see i've seen a lot you know so i
think it's i think it's an exciting time
uh for content in general for whether
it's you know commercial movies or
independent films i'm getting told we
have to get it we have to hustle you
down to the new bev but i just want to
say thanks for making this it's so fun
to have a great summertime horror
summertime's the best time to have a
horror i don't know why yeah i think so
too
and um thank you so much and thanks
everybody for coming out thank you for
coming
[Music]
you